salut la nasa nous sommes très heureux
de vous retrouver notre invité principal
ce soir c'est roland dumas
alors bonsoir bonsoir vous avait 88 ans
oui vous avez été un ténor du barreau
vous avez été ministre des affaires
étrangères de françois mitterrand est
aussi son ami mais vous êtes ici ce soir
pour répondre à une question que tout le
monde se pose depuis des années comment
on se sent dans des chaussures berluti à
2000 euros
ça va c'est confortable ce prix là moi
bien alors voulons vous connaissez les
missions en père nous serons tous les
deux nous parlerons de vous de vos
origines de votre enfance de votre
adolescence de vos études votre carrière
de vos succès de vos échecs et nous
reviendrons sur vos chaussures berluti à
2000 euros un smic à chaque pied c'est
pas gênant pour un socialiste non parce
que j'ai vu que le secrétaire du
syndicat fo qui avait fait cette courbe
par exemple avait lui-même des ennuis
parce qu'ils ne paient pas sûr personnel
le plus chaud qu'on s'était pas les
chaussures à 2000 euros c'étaient les
chaussettes à 3000 euros quand même ça
je n'avais pas
salut les terriens et le bronze
vraiment de fortune
[Musique]
alors roland dumas re bonsoir vous êtes
né le 23 août 1922 à limoges votre père
georges dumas fonctionnaires des
finances membre du parti socialiste son
destin a activement participé à la
résistance au sein de l'armée secrète et
puis un jour
mon pauvre roland il eût mieux valu ne
pas rentrer à limoges le malheur qui
nous frappe est épouvantable c'est par
ce mot griffonné par votre mère mais
elle fait passer par un mystère
clandestins lui même et on a fait porter
parce qu'elle était la seule à connaître
l'endroit où je me cachais elle et moi
et vous apprenez la mort de votre père
qui avait été dénoncée arrêté par la
gestapo fusillé à brantôme sur le
cadavre de votre père vous trouvez une
fiche assez laconique georges dumas
terroristes
exactement alors vous êtes obligé de
reconnaître les restes exhumés de votre
père moment épouvantable pour vous
évidemment une alliance un bridge un
bout de veston enfin c'est un morceau de
cravate un morceau car les ce qu'ils
auraient exécuté avait requis deux
personnes dans le pays et pour les
enterrer à même la terre car elle
n'avait pas circulé et
le celui qui étaient quittes charge est
chargé de les mettre dans le sol avaient
coupé en corse cachant un morceau de sa
cravate et nous allons les organisations
de résistance dont l'avait fait passer
pour qu'on puisse identifier à la fois
le corps et savoir où il était alors
voilà la mort de votre père a deux
conséquences
vous dites je n'aurais sans doute pas eu
la même vie si mon père avait vécu sans
doute très certainement vous pensez que
vous auriez une vie moins dissolue
rolland sort c'est très difficile vous
avez déclaré en ce qui concerne les
affaires privées et au vue de la morale
je ne suis pas un exemple
oui et vous avez déclaré aussi vous
savez ce que je ferais inscriptions ma
tombe j'ai bien vécu je ne change pas la
devise
je pense encore imprimés
[Applaudissements]
autre conséquence de la mort de votre
père disparition de toutes vos
ressources financières agir dans la gêne
à ce moment là mon père était donc
fonctionnaires de l'état versée oui mais
comme il est et vielles par les
allemands les réactions étaient connues
tout de suite à vichy on lui a suspendu
son traitement dans la perversion va
vers le lendemain de son exécution en
coin et que l'on a vécu à l'époque de
l'aide je dois le dire des syndicats et
du et des clandestins est ce que c'est
de là que date votre peur de manquer à
peut-être je ne savais pas que vous
étiez psychanalyste mais après tout
pourquoi pas alors voilà pendant la
guerre vous êtes vous aussi impliqués
dans la résistance vous convoyer des
armes dans la région de grenoble vous
serez arrêtés par la police française
interné dans un fort et décoré de la
croix de guerre la libération
vous avez toujours su mieux résister aux
allemands que je dis fille roland
[Musique]
alors voilà vous avez vos études à
l'époque vous rêvez des diplomates mais
vous n'avez pas assez d'argent oui j'ai
fini
par y
avait aussi d'une carrière dans le
lyrique vous apprenez le solfège
préparer le conservatoire mais en fait
vous deviendrez ténor du barreau d'un
grand avocat vous occuper de la sphère
benbarka l'opposant marocain à mohamed 5
vous vous occupez de l'assassinât de
stefan markovic
je viens d'avoir de la famille markovics
pour markovic vous savez quoi
tout ce que je ne peux pas dire
[Applaudissements]
vous avez été aussi l'avocat du canard
enchaîné la dst avait mis des micros
canard enchaîné et la sphère des micros
qui a provoqué le plus fort tirage du
cadarache et de trop d'histoires vous
avez été également l'avocat du monde des
arts et des lettres chagall picasso
braque giacometti mais la grande
rencontre de votre vie c'est évidemment
françois mitterrand alors à l'époque
vous le rencontrez vous êtes simple
député mais vous comprenez dites vous
qu'il va devenir quelqu'un de célèbre en
france tous les gens qui l'ont connu
qu'ils ont rencontrés estiment que le
seul fait de son apparition chez le
parent dans un cercle de l'être humain
d'amis ou de simplement un cercle
politique il a impressionné par sa seule
présence du reste il avait su rla sur la
politique et sur le destin du pays et
sur les mesures qui s'imposaient il
avait quand même une vision que je n'ai
pas retrouvé partout ailleurs
il ya une phrase que vous détestez mais
je suis quand même vous la dire c'est
quand on dit vous mitterrand avait deux
avocats badinter pour le droit et dumas
pour le 30 août ça vous énerve
donc ça me fait rire oui j'ai jamais pu
savoir qui avait inventé cette formule
roger patrice pelât harry oui peut-être
ne croyez pas je ne suis pas sûr qu'il
avait autant d'esprit
voilà en tous les cas
avec françois mitterrand et dalida vous
montez au panthéon en 1980 mais il
faudra attendre 1983 pour qu'il vous
nomme ministre des affaires européennes
et 1988
profil vous nomme ministre affaires
étrangères
alors c'est dû à quoi relancer vos
mauvaises fréquentations
c'est vrai vous faisiez la noce en
espagne avec placido domingo est la
veuve de yul brynner une vie dissolue
régionales et puis alors cette fameuse
lucienne goldfarb alias katia la
rouquine patronne d'un hôtel de passe
rue du débarcadère et qui avait le même
bout pour l'opéra dont cetin avocat
ouais c'est ça alors je ne connais rien
vous en dis je ce intérêt vu la première
fois pour les apprenants parler ces
dossiers qui étaient nombreux difficile
et on a pardonné bifurqué sur l'opéra et
c'est elle qui m'a fait connaître ainsi
domingo voilà vous avez fait avec elle
une association d'amis de l'opéra qui
s'appelle operalia oui que domingo ma
demande de présider voilà arrivé aussi
nadeo jay la fille du général classe que
l'hyper en appeler votre belle syrienne
10 euros il sait très admirative
mitterrand avait du goût oui
et puis après bien sûr il ya eu
christine deviers joncour la fameuse
[ __ ] de la république alors ce qu'on
sait moins en fait c'est qu'à cette
époque cauchemardesque de l' affaire elf
vous aviez vraiment certaines nuits
envie de vous suicidez vous pensez
bourthois un des lego voir le pensait
plus qu'à 100 à la nuit vous réveiller
en sursaut à 3 heures du matin vous
voyez tous les jours depuis vous vous
réveillez vous vous demandez si vous
étiez dans un cauchemar ou s'il en était
et vous revoyez les choses et un ce
moment là vaut boyer du noir ne pourrez
plus vous rendre c'est une spirale
regardez ce pauvre eric aux voix ouais
il n'avait rien à se reprocher notre
ancien mais il s'est suicidé parce qu'il
n'avait plus de ressort il était au bout
de la spirale et c'est ça le problème et
je vais vous savez comment j'ai été un
tournant dans votre appartement à un
moment je suis arrivé dans un couloir où
j'avais des décades et j'ai toujours eu
je l'est encore aujourd'hui la cale
qu'avait mon père et j'ai regardé cette
can et je me suis dit j'ai revu tout de
suite il va j'ai mon père je me suis dit
tu vas pas le refaire oui la grâce de
mettre fin à ses jours ce qui sera signé
dans l'exactitude et d'autres pas la
monstruosité de la chose alors
globalement est-ce que ça a été plutôt
sympa d'être roland dumas dans la vie
oui oui je ne regrette rien ouais je
referais le même parcours réfléchir jeu
bien sûr bien sûr je me prendrai
peut-être autrement mais enfin je
n'aurais pas moins de sévérité à l'égard
de ceux qui m'ont cherché qui me
retrouver car je pense qu'à une chose
c'est que tous ceux qui tous ceux qui
pendant vous lui confiez vos confrères
du journal le monde ils sont sur le
sable ouais le juge d'instruction n'ont
plus d'instruction bah écoutez vous êtes
très beau la très très bien on sent des
hackers joumblatt
est très en forme
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus